that is nearly it but we go just time
for a quick visit to the big red
chair now alan is all set there he is
he's ready he's ready
uh okay let's find out uh who's going to
be trying to keep you in that chair
who's up first hello hi
what's your name francesca francesca and
where are you francesca
i'm in north finchley in london lovely i
don't like the color of your curtains
they're not mine i'm
[Laughter]
i'm an actor and i also work in a local
pub okay
so nothing um
unemployed i've been there it gets
better
thank you please put me on bridgeton i'd
love to be on it
yeah yeah all right off we go with your
story and remember you're trying to keep
alan in that chair
okay good luck everyone off you go okay
so a few years ago
i was working in sheffield in a theatre
and we have this barn restaurant where
the audience and cast
would come before and after a show one
night this famous person had been to see
the show
and came into the bar afterwards where i
served them um and i was making their
drinks i think it was like
two gin and tonics and as i was making
their drinks these two cast members came
over and started asking for their photos
and that kind of thing
so i put the drinks on the bar they turn
around pick up their drinks
and then walk over to their table
without paying now you're probably
wondering who this famous person is
it was graham and orton
i knew it was gonna be me i
never pay for drinks
how dare she ask me for money
i'm supporting live theater
it was an accident i'm so sorry alan
can you warn me next time you've been
tight can you just warn me
[Music]
you